[Música]
hola bienvenidos a áfrica siete días
hasta su magazine 100% dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre es andrés
meza muñoz y estos son nuestros
titulares a los 85 años murió el ex
presidente sudafricano frederick de
klerk el último mandatario del apartheid
y quien compartió el premio nobel de la
paz con su sucesor nelson mandela por
haber contribuido a poner fin al sistema
de segregación racial antes de su muerte
grabó el mensaje en el que pidió perdón
por el daño causado
siguen las protestas contra el golpe de
estado en su daño al menos cinco
personas murieron el pasado 3 de
noviembre en medio de la represión de
las fuerzas de seguridad las nuevas
movilizaciones se dieron luego de que el
jefe del ejército conformará un consejo
de transición para dirigir el país la
reconocida fotógrafa maliense para tu
mata de abate visitó colombia para
instalar su famoso estudio de calle es
la primera vez que el proyecto llega a
un país de américa latina y hace parte
de una tradición heredada de grandes
fotógrafos de áfrica occidental un
equipo de france 24 la acompañó en su
recorrido les contamos de qué se trata
empezamos en sudáfrica porque el pasado
11 de noviembre murió a los 85 años el
ex presidente frederick de klerk a causa
de un cáncer que afecta el tejido de los
pulmones el político fue reconocido por
su lucha en contra del régimen de la
partería el supremacismo blanco en el
país por lo que ganó el premio nobel de
la paz junto a nelson mandela en 1993
antes de morir declare grabó un mensaje
en el que se disculpaba por los daños
causados por el régimen de la parte
permítanme hoy en este último mensaje
repetir yo sin reservas
les
pido disculpas por el dolor y las
heridas la indignidad y el daño que
aparte ha hecho a los negros morenos e
indios en sudáfrica
pero veamos quién era frederick de klerk
y cuál fue su legado en la historia y la
política sudafricana
fue todo un icono en sudáfrica frederik
de klerk nació en el seno de una familia
ultra conservadora abogado de formación
a los 36 años se afilió al partido
nacional de corte segregacionista y
racista con el que estuvo al frente de
carteras como la de educación y
servicios sociales y no fue hasta 1989
con 53 años cuando declare que se
convirtió en presidente de sudáfrica
frederik willem de klerk juró ser leal a
la república de sudáfrica
y aunque al principio no se posicionó en
contra del racismo sólo tardó un año en
proclamarse en contra del apartheid en
el parlamento de sudáfrica un sistema
político y social que permitió una
minoría blanca gobernar de forma
discriminatoria durante 42 años sobre
una mayoría de afros indios y mestizos
de manera quien levantó la prohibición
del partido congreso nacional africano y
pidió la liberación del activista negro
nelson mandela tras 27 años en la cárcel
se anula la prohibición del congreso
nacional africano del congreso
panafricanista y el partido comunista
sudafricano junto a sus organizaciones
afiliadas dos años más tarde el
presidente consiguió tumbar la ley
blanca a través de un referendo y
modificar la constitución con el
respaldo del 70% de los votantes
hoy se ha terminado el libro del
apartheid y ese capítulo está finalmente
zanjado
además de conseguir una sociedad más
igualitaria estas acciones le hicieron
ganar el premio nobel de la paz junto a
nelson mandela en 1993 y le brindaron el
respeto de la activista afro
de klerk tuve el coraje de admitir la
terrible equivocación que se cometió en
sudáfrica sólo un año después de klerk
perdió las elecciones contra mandela
iniciando un profundo cambio político en
el país y haciendo historia como el
último presidente blanco hasta la
actualidad
vamos a sudar en al menos cinco
manifestantes murieron el pasado 13 de
noviembre en jartúm en medio de la
represión de las fuerzas de seguridad a
una nueva jornada de movilizaciones en
contra del golpe de estado dirigido por
el general abdelfatah al burhan
en este vídeo amateur un hombre herido
es evacuado rápidamente por los
manifestantes
aquí los opositores muestran los
casquillos de lo que según ellos fueron
balas reales disparadas por las fuerzas
de seguridad con el acceso a internet
cortado desde hace tres semanas los
manifestantes se han visto obligados a
organizarse mediante mensajes de texto o
grafitis en las paredes
decenas de miles de sudaneses salieron a
las calles de jartúm para gritar no al
gobierno militar
queremos que el consejo militar sea
derrocado y que vuelva el gobierno civil
estamos hartos de este poder militar y
no queremos que un soldado nos gobierne
una escolástica el papel de los
militares pues estar en el poder nuestra
política sino proteger la constitución
a la que el general al culto se ha
opuesto cuando como el poder tras curar
respetarla
el jueves el general abdel fatah al
burham autor del golpe reformó el
consejo soberano de transición volvió a
nombrar a los militares ya civiles no
políticos para sustituir a los que
abogaron por una transferencia completa
del poder a los civiles estos
nombramientos fueron rechazados por eeuu
y varios países europeos que también
exigieron la restitución inmediata del
primer ministro a barajando desde el
golpe de estado del 25 de octubre al
menos 18 personas han muerto y más de
300 han resultado heridas en la
represión de las manifestaciones los
militares tendrán que dar muestras de
moderación para tranquilizar a la
comunidad internacional que condena al
golpe de estado en sudán
con el propósito de que los jóvenes
ruandeses se aficionen a la lectura la
asociación wanda book mobile distribuye
libros y organiza sesiones de lecturas
públicas en todo el país transportan sus
libros en bicicleta y su objetivo es
recorrer todos los rincones de ruanda
para promocionar la historia y la
cultura ruandesa nuestra corresponsal
marian cone nos informa
recuerden las ciudades o mesas en
bicicleta con libros como único equipaje
el objetivo leer historias a los niños
para inculcarles la pasión por la
lectura
todo el mundo sabe que ruanda es un país
con muchas colinas pero no vemos ninguna
limitación porque sabemos que nos
divertiremos con los niños de hoy apagan
sus bicicletas en esta escuela primaria
de 5 abu en el este del país
esa despierta a sus amigos y les dice
vengan a ver vengan a verlo
todos los libros que lean los
voluntarios de la asociación one that
book mobile se inspiran en la cultura
ruandesa una forma para los niños de
aprender más sobre la historia de su
país
para innovar con cameron
tenemos que recordar que somos africanos
somos ruandeses somos narradores y
estamos reviviendo esta práctica a
través de los libros porque a veces los
padres no saben dónde pueden encontrar
las historias y los libros son la
primera fuente de inspiración book
that's the first soft para mantener viva
la pasión por la lectura en los lugares
donde ya han estado los miembros de la
asociación ayudan a construir
bibliotecas y los pueblos y a formar a
los bibliotecarios para que lean en
público como emanuel 50 bibliotecarios
han participado en los cursos de
formación de la asociación
aprendí a hacer mi trabajo de forma
diferente y hoy me siento feliz al ver
que puedo dar alegría a los niños me
siento orgulloso y útil para mi
comunidad la sociedad ha creado en 2019
la asociación ha participado en la
creación de más de 10 bibliotecas en
wanda su próximo objetivo es distribuir
bicicletas a los bibliotecarios de todo
el país
pato mata de abate es una artista
maliense reconocida internacionalmente
por su estudio fotográfico de calle con
el que recorre el mundo para fotografiar
a las personas según una tradición
heredada de grandes fotógrafos de áfrica
occidental por primera vez la retratista
pudo instalar su estudio en américa
latina y más precisamente en colombia un
equipo de france 24 siguió su recorrido
buenaventura cali y bogotá
son las ciudades colombianas que
recibieron el estudio de calle de la
fotógrafa maliense fatoumata de abate es
su primera vez en américa latina
este estudio cree encuentros nos tocamos
nos abrazamos estamos en el mundo hoy el
que todos los confíen de los demás pero
este estudio nos permite hacer carnes
heredera de malick sidibé uno de los
padres fundadores de la fotografía
maliense la artista viaja por el mundo
reavivando la tradición fotográfica que
comenzó hace más de medio siglo en
áfrica occidental de la fotografía y que
cuando la fotografía entregó a áfrica
inmediatamente los fotógrafos africanas
apropiaron de ella a través de los
estudios de este tipo de ejemplo y al
fotógrafo para pedir hay fotos que luego
enviaban a sus familiares en su pueblo a
menudo para mostrar su nueva vida en la
ciudad de familia l foto en el en el
estudio los accesorios vintage son
protagonistas y al vestir a sus modelos
fatoumata borra las barreras del tiempo
y del espacio y los transporta a la
bamako de los años 60 luego los
participantes se van con su foto tema de
las telas de la música la alegría que
tiene la gente para quien apareció en
vano en buenaventura la principal ciudad
con población afrodescendiente de
colombia para muchos fue la oportunidad
de conectarse con áfrica y aunque se
diga que se trata de dos culturas
nosotros somos una sola cultura
venimos de áfrica ahí está nuestro
origen la cuna de la humanidad y
encontrar una mujer que viene y que la
sentimos como no es cree que ella al
llegar aquí se siente como en casa es
algo muy muy emocionante después de
buenaventura
la fotógrafa recorrió
116 kilómetros para llegar a calle
allí la primera parada fue el mercado
principal de la ciudad donde transeúntes
se animaron a experimentar el proyecto
luego en el barrio siloé bastión de las
protestas sociales de 2021 en colombia
el taller fue para los jóvenes que
estuvieron al frente de las
manifestaciones
la última parada de la gira colombiana
de la artista fue bogotá
el recorrido de la toma está por
colombia se dio gracias al empeño de qui
tambo una fundación que trabaja en el
acercamiento entre áfrica y el país
suramericano
dentro de toda la diversidad hay muchas
similitudes
somos parecidos y tenemos mucho que
compartir músculos shows
hasta 10 en este compartir que nos damos
cuenta de todo lo que nos sube mucho
como la calidez de los colombianos dejó
una fuerte impresión en la artista se va
con el recuerdo de una experiencia
inolvidable que pretende repetir pronto
en otro país de américa latina
hasta aquí este capítulo de áfrica siete
días recuerde que si quiere repetir esta
u otra emisión de nuestro programa lo
puede hacer a través de nuestra página
web www punto frente 4 puntocom
[Música]